yeah i'm not that into pie or donates  but i tell you what i love  hot cheetos in the black bag takis i  like the spicy  what about wow chocolate chip cookies  yeah those are delicious too ted i don't  discriminate  i like all types of junk food and i just  had junk food about 30 minutes ago  confirmation christian  yes nothing no green tongue no blue  tongue  what was eating over there it was a blue  doughnut from las vegas now  las vegas now tons of sugar yeah  christian was like you're going to have  blue lips now and i don't think yeah  you're good buddy i think i'm good all  right  right so since we have las vegas now yes  i  i think my junk food intake will has  gone up  that's all right it looked really good  though i really did  i'm a sucker for blue donuts